un peu de sport à présent et le TVB
obtient une nouvelle victoire en Ligue
des champions en battant Lubiana 37 à 0
en match retour à domicile hier soir les
tourangeau se sont offerts une place en
phase finale du prestigieux tournoi
européen après avoir battu l'équipe sur
le même score à l'allé le TVB n'avait
besoin de gagner que deux sets pour être
assuré de poursuivre la compétition
voilà 2 ans de suite que l'équipe accède
à cette étape l'an dernier ils avaient
quitté la compétition 8e de finale mais
cette année on vise évidemment la
victoire retour sur ce match d'entologie
à la Hal Grenon avec l
turqu ils l'ont fait dans un palais des
sports enflammé le tour volleyball
assure sa place en play-off de la Ligue
des Champions qualification assurée dès
le second set remporté et quitte à faire
les choses bien le TVB s'offre un 3-0
contre les
Slovènes je suis super fier en tant
qu'entraîneur c'est la deuxè fois que
j'ai l'opportunité de jouer la Champions
League et on se qualifie sont très
acharnés on a vécu et vous le savez très
bien en début de saison délicat et je
pense que c'est même cette ligue des
champions qui qui nous a redonné les
bons chemins c'est une aventure qui
continue avec un groupe qui qui sait
trouver des ressources les ressources il
faut tout de même aller les chercher
surtout quand c'est luubliana qui prend
les devant en s'offrant les trois
premiers points de la soirée à chaque 7
c'est la même histoire le TVB est mené
puis joue des coues jusqu'à devancer les
Slovènes à coup de bloc de Parkinson ou
d'attaque de mendz comme pour achev ce
deè
set on a eu du mal à se mettre en route
ils nous ont mis une bonne pression
bonne pression au service bloc donc
voilà ça a été le temps d'adaptation
pour nous
et c'est bien parce qu'on a vite réagi
on n pas fait notre notre meilleur match
mais on a été on a été bon dans les dans
les moments importants et et ça c'est
c'est ce qui nous caractérise depuis
depuis plusieurs matchs privé de ces
deux pointus Dramé et faganas tout de
blessés le TVB a dû s'adapter et changer
sa configuration un Paris qui s avéré
gagnant on on a mis en pointu donc c'est
c'est la première fois et voilà il était
invvp donc on a beaucoup de potentiel
pour changer pour pour voir si si
quelque chose marche pas pour ce soir
c'était pas juste la routine pour pour
finir la la qualification ce soir
c'était un match un peu délicat à mon
avis mais on a bien tenu mentalement on
a on a gagné ces matchs la compétition
européenne continue donc pour les tours
enjau pour la 2uxe année d'affilée ils
affronteront cette fois l'équipe de
Berlin dans de semaines ici à
[Applaudissements]
grena